it's about finding forgiveness for the
man who gave us both life and also hurt
us the most
Jada pinkett-smith opening up about her
relationship with her late father Robson
Pinkett jr. I was sick and that's what
he told me like he was protecting you
Bible oh yeah I mean that's what he told
me at seven yeah mm-hmm
I can't be your father right yeah I'm a
criminal I'm an addict and that's just
what it is in a new episode of read
Table Talk dude his younger brother
Caleb joins to talk about struggles they
faced with her dad at prior to his death
in 2010 we both had a lot of resentment
we have that feeling like we had to be
responsible for him but he never had to
be responsible for it though Jada and
Caleb grew up with different mothers and
in different states
they agreed their father is a shared
source of pain and admit Rob still
struggled with drugs and alcohol his
entire life I'd rather get hide and be
your father yep like that's hardcore
when he said yes but there was a reason
behind it for him and his reason was I
was sick it takes practice to have those
difficult conversations with kindness
and consideration and it's just
something that we have to continue to
practice because if we don't talk about
it we're not going to get to the other
side we're just gonna you know things
are just gonna stay in the cracks and
fester so the more that we can bring
these difficult subjects to light and
talk about it the more we can purify
these subjects and bring them into
something new
their father relapsed after almost three
years of sobriety and died from an
overdose the most difficult part of him
dying like that is because he and I had
had a horrendous fight when I found out
that he relapsed mm-hmm I was like I
don't owe you nothing you didn't do for
me you didn't do the Caleb I don't owe
you nothing it was one of those mm-hmm
I have not been able to fully forgive
myself
for the way I treated my father before
losing him when I talk about it I can
start crying like quickly and that means
it's unresolved within me
Jana shared with ety tackling topics
like forgiveness at the table is so
important it was amazing to be here at
the red tip a lot happens at the red tip
explain to me what it's all about well
the red table is a place of testimony
you know and a place where we get to
share our story share our experiences
and get to really talk and spill our
truth in a very wrong way that's wasn't
say there's a lot of truth that's coming
out at this table from what I understand
it's a lot it's really unique it's three
generations regeneration and I'm hoping
that it will give people the freedom
also in their lives to find their truth
and to have more courage to live their
truth because really that's what this
table is about you know is us finding
out you sometimes discovering our truth
and having the courage to live that
truth you know and so that's all this
table is about sharing and discovery
[Music]